sending email is a fundamental feature
that's required by almost every app
today I'm going to show you how to
combine the powers of SendGrid
and firebase cloud functions to send
transactional email to your customers it
works like this a new document is
created in firestore that triggers a
cloud function the cloud function that
makes an API called ascend grid and send
grid sends the emails to your users in
this video we're going to use a fire
stork database trigger but you can also
trigger the function over HTTP and I
already wrote the code for that which is
at angular firebase comm if you're just
finding me for the first time make sure
to subscribe and then head over to
SendGrid to sign up for a free account
it's free if you send less than a
hundred emails per day and then after
that you pay based on volume from there
you'll need to initialize firebase
functions in your project I'm going to
be working in the context of an angular
5 app but this code will work for any
firebase enabled project from there you
can CD into the functions directory then
we'll install send grids nodejs library
send grid has several other packages for
node but the mail package should handle
90% of your use cases if we go into
package JSON it should look something
like this we have sending grid mail and
then I also have cores installed for
HTTP but we're not going to cover that
in this video but check out the link in
the description if you need the HTTP
version of this cloud function from
there you'll want to go into your send
grid account and create a new API key
keep in mind this is a sensitive API key
so don't expose it in your front-end
code or any other public facing
application then you'll set it to your
functions environment by calling
firebase functions config set a send
grid key with your corresponding API key
now before we write the cloud function I
want to show you how I manage
transactional templates in send grid a
template holds all the default HTML and
styles associated with an email and then
we can pass it dynamic data from our
cloud function to display specific user
information inside of the email in this
demo we're going to send an email to the
user every time they receive a new
follower SendGrid has a drag-and-drop
editor that makes editing your templates
very easy managing email HTML and CSS
can often be very frustrating but the
editor can significantly increase your
productivity for example if we want to
add an image to our email we can simply
drag and drop that from the saved images
on our send grid account
that allows you to provide consistent
branding and reusable components across
all of your emails the most important
thing I want to look at is how we pass
dynamic data to our email template first
look at the name with the double curly
brackets that's going to be our custom
dynamic data that we send from the cloud
function you can add as much custom data
with this syntax to your email as you
want then SendGrid has a few built-in
variables for example the body which is
wrapped here in the % it might be easier
to use the body tag if you're generating
all of your email content on the server
at this point we can save the template
and then make a note of the ID now we
can switch back to our firebase cloud
function code and the first thing we'll
do is import the admin database and then
we're going to set our SendGrid api key
by calling functions config send grid
key then we can initialize the send grid
client by importing it and then calling
s gmail set API key I'm going to give
our cloud function a name firestore
email and it's going to be triggered
whenever a user gets a new follower and
a follower is a document that's nested
under the main user document it's a
somewhat contrived example but I just
want to show you how to trigger the
actual email sending process when that
event happens we want to send an email
to the user who received the follower
the first thing I'm doing is setting the
user ID as a variable and then I'm going
to make a reference to the firestore
database from there I query the users
document by calling DB collection users
with that corresponding user ID and then
we call get to receive the snapshot and
then with that document we get the
actual data on the document by calling
doc data now the message object is what
we actually send a send grid so this has
to be formatted in a specific way it
needs to have a two email which will be
the users email from this document and
then it'll be from angular firebase com
the subject will be a new follower but
you can also set that on the template
itself then you use the email template
by setting that template ID property
with that ID that we copied in the
previous step you can use your own
custom templating syntax by adding them
to substitution wrappers I'm just
sticking with the double curly brackets
like they would work in an angular app
then the substitutions object will
contain all your custom dynamic data
we're just adding the users display name
but you could also add things like their
follower account or any other relevant
information to this email sending the
email as easy as calling s Gmail send
with this message object that's going to
return a promise so we'll go ahead and
console.log message sent or console.log
the error if an error happened to occur
here and that's all it takes now we just
have to deploy the function and then
we'll verify that it works by creating a
new document and firestore going into
firestore i'm here on the user's
collection and then under my user
account then I'm going to nest a
followers collection under it and then
add a document to it it doesn't matter
what's inside this document I'm just
going to add a field that says hello
world clicking create should invoke the
function and we should see an email in
our inbox before I do that I'm going to
go over to the cloud function logs and
make sure that we don't have any errors
we see email sent in the function logs
meaning that SendGrid did send a
successful response back to the function
keep in mind that you need to have
billing enabled in firebase to send
outside API calls so if you have any
errors at this point make sure to double
check that if I go to my gmail account I
see I get the email here from angular
firebase comm via send grid net and my
name is interpolated where the curly
brackets were that's it for firebase
cloud functions with send grid if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn more
advanced techniques with transactional
email consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get a free
copy of my book exclusive content and
one on one project consulting thanks for
watching and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]